it was a one-time slip-up it doesn't
change who i am who is that exactly
stop well what
you gonna kill me again or are other
people gonna die because that's what
always happens right
hey guys pete here this will be my
breakdown for dexter new blood episode
3. smoke signals saw the investigation
into matt's disappearance continue to
bring trouble to dexter's front doorstep
and make things difficult in developing
his relationship with harrison we
learned that there is definitely another
murderer in town and get the arrival of
a new character a famous true crime
podcaster from la although based on the
promo images that were released for this
episode it looks like they cut one of
her scenes the one where she meets
dexter at work but we do get a new
character just the same and a lot more
of kurt caldwell who injected a really
strange twist into the ending of the
episode and we'll get into all of that
i'll recap everything that happened and
then come back and give you my thoughts
on everything at the end right after
this quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched the third installment of
dexter new blood yet then this video
isn't for you and with that out of the
way let's get into it this opens with
dexter wanting to get everyone off his
land they're literally hanging out just
above matt's remains he needs to take
harrison to school for the first time
and on their way he hears there's been a
break in the case angela and kurt are
going to the station and she doesn't
give him any details and he's definitely
distracted with that at the high school
and things are pretty weird there
anyways because he doesn't really know
much about harrison they were just
reintroduced to each other and there's
some discrepancies with his grades going
up and down erratically in his records
he explains to the principal that it's
because his stepmom died and that leads
to her asking about how he ended up in
foster care how come they didn't get a
hold of dexter and he didn't come there
in the first place and we see that
harrison has the instinct to lie and
cover for jim lindsey in this case
saying it's not his fault in an effort
to stay close to the investigation
dexter goes into the station there he
learns that they have footage of matt
shooting the deer on reservation lands
it turns out it's only a thermal imaging
camera though so it's heat signatures
rather than images where you can see
details they found matt dexter was able
to identify his rifle but then they also
caught dexter walking with his rifle in
the next closest quadrant now it's a
criminal investigation and that means
they have to go back where the deer was
shot and start working it as a crime
scene and here we see that kirk caldwell
is pissed and he blows up on angela back
at the cabin she's upset because she
called off the search when they found
the glove which is exactly what dexter
set up what he wanted to happen and we
see that his manipulation of the
situation only worked for so long the
csi shows up and he looks clumsy which
makes dexter feel better he asks him if
he can come along and watch and kurt
says that he's coming too because it's
his son when they get there he turns out
to be very confident he notices that
some of the blood coagulated differently
and decides to test it and that leads to
him finding out it's human and then when
he's asked he basically reenacts exactly
what happened just from the crime scene
and it makes you think about dexter
working for miami pd as he's playing it
out he notices the rock is missing so
they know there was an attacker and some
kind of altercation where the blood was
hidden on purpose and the rock was
removed so they know it's foul play it's
clear there was an attack and someone
tried to cover it up and dexter thinks
to himself that he's gotten rusty in his
abstinence dexter gets a call to come to
the school and again we see that
everything in relation to harrison is
becoming a distraction from what he
really wants to do which is not get
caught for killing matt harrison got a
higher score than any other student but
the teacher left the room for 15 minutes
and basically now they think he must
have used his phone and cheated and
dexter doesn't really back him up and
we'll see that come back around later
back at his cabin dexter learns that
they're bringing in search dogs tomorrow
which is a new level of stress and he
goes through it in his head fighting
with deb he says it's a one-time slip up
that doesn't change who he is but she
rightly points out that usually in these
kinds of situations people end up dying
and all he can really say is not this
time no harrison tells him that he
retook the test and did better the
second time but dex is distracted with
how he's gonna move the body or at least
keep them off his trail until he can
figure it out elsewhere in the
investigation they had done a familial
dna swab on kurt so angela has to call
him and tell him that the blood they
found is a match he freaks out on her
again and all she can say is that she'll
be out there looking and they're gonna
find his son after harrison goes to
sleep dex digs up the bags with matt's
body and pulls out his vest he uses that
to create a scent trail back to the
highway from the crime scene so that the
dogs will be confused when they come in
the next day then we go back to the
story of the girl from the bar she's
still trapped in the room the person is
watching on a laptop apparently he's a
fan of the showrunner clyde phillips's
books we see them sitting there on his
desk and he puts on a record and gets
dressed for the outdoors with a ski mask
and a parka and then hits a button on
the computer that opens the door she
realizes she can make it outside so she
puts on her jacket and runs and the
killer is waiting he shoots her in the
back with his rifle with the laser scope
before she can make it very far from
where she was being held later we see
this hunter slash killer is washing the
body in a room that's set up pretty well
he's actually embalming the body which i
don't know why he needs to do that but
it stands out that it's a professional
looking setup from what we can see
the search dogs do arrive and we see
molly show up at the crime scene where
she introduces herself to angela as a
citizen activist and we'll get some more
details about who she is when they all
get together later for dinner so the
setup is established that dexter has to
deal with this issue he's got a dead
body on his property and when he drops
harrison off at school he thinks about
where he might be able to take it it's a
pretty funny back and forth with deb
where he crosses off the different
options until she suggests a wood
chipper olive fargo with everything set
up all the characters kind of go on
their own little side stories angela
goes to the reservation to question one
of the hunters on the list we hear the
name iris get thrown out there again how
the two of them were close and they had
ideas about leaving together and at one
point she says please don't make this
about iris and we really still don't
understand who this person is based on
what audrey says later there's also the
possibility that this is her mother who
left right after she was born at school
harrison finds out that zach and scott
are catfishing another student in the
lunchroom he sits with him and tells him
what's going on later he has this kid
ethan send a picture of zack having sex
with a goat and when he comes for him
harrison intervenes grabbing him by the
throat and threatening him and it works
he tells him to leave ethan alone and
there's nothing that zach does in that
moment after that audrey offers him a
ride home they seem to be hitting it off
they stop at the butcher shop and they
find out that the white buck is still
inside the cooler she's upset that
they're gonna throw it away like
roadkill and harrison throws it out
there that they should try to do
something with it before that happens
after that he finds out that her father
died and that her birth mother abandoned
her right after she was born
she has car trouble which means harrison
has to leave to make a call where he can
get bars and in the meantime ed olson
shows up he offers to let her sit in his
car where it's warm while she waits and
then she lays into him about how much
polluting his companies do and the
millions he spent on blocking climate
science this gives him the chance to say
that people are complicated and that one
day she'll understand how things really
work and then later at home harrison
gets a call from ethan thanking him and
he shows him some crazy violent drawings
where he's dressed like what you would
think a school shooter might wear i
don't know what other point they're
trying to make here and it does feel
like ethan is harboring some deep
resentment that could turn violent
dexter gets called in for questioning by
logan they're interviewing everyone that
talked to matt while he was in town and
dex tells him that the last time he saw
him was at his party logan then asked
him to identify the rifle in the heat
signature photo of himself and since
it's the most common one he tells him
the truth but he doesn't seem too
worried since there's so many of those
in town
then he takes off on a fruitless trip to
the iron mines where he runs into a bear
and then all the different characters
come back together for dinner at
angela's place audrey says she can't
believe molly park is in iron lake she's
a famous podcaster audrey says it's one
of the most popular in the true crime
genre she says she has over a million
followers on instagram
and dexter mentions that he met her at
work earlier that day which is related
to the scene it looks like they cut out
while they're together at dinner dexter
reflects on how he can't believe he
found the family here in iron lake and
how he doesn't want to lose it and we
find out they have plans to take the
white buck to the reservation for a
ceremony and bonfire while they're there
dexter apologizes to harrison for not
standing up for him at the school and we
see that he's echoing the same things
that angela was saying when she was
talking to audrey he saw those two have
a moment so he tried to recreate that
with his son then he gets the idea to
take matt's body to the iron lake
sanitation incinerator and he's able to
get rid of it so all the other stuff he
was doing is pretty much for naught and
as far as we can tell the body is taken
care of then on his way home he sees a
drunk curt outside the tavern he thinks
to himself that something looks off like
he doesn't look like a grieving father
and decides to pull over and talk to him
he's obviously drunk but he tells dexter
that he talked to matt and not just that
he talked to him on the phone but that
he facetimed with him and obviously
dexter knows this isn't the case he just
burnt the body but he gives him a ride
home thinking why is he lying about this
and the episode ends there
i thought this episode was on par with
the last one it was sort of on the same
level it had some funny moments and a
lot of setup there's a good amount of
character development that seems focused
in a way that the side stories and the
early seasons of dexter were not if that
pays off in a satisfying way then i'm
all for it it could be an improvement
but definitely not reinventing the wheel
in a way if you were just hoping for a
return to form of those early dexter
seasons then this is kind of exactly
that but then i kind of wonder is that
enough for there to be a whole revival
and i go back to that idea that i
mentioned in my first video that i think
this is all going to come down to how
the ending plays out i can watch a new
season of dexter that occurs in a
different location and enjoy it just for
nostalgia's sake but i'm hoping they
have a really good idea in mind for why
they wanted to come back and revisit it
so in the last episode there was a focus
on dexter's fears about harrison having
dark tendencies we saw that he wrote
about that in his letter to hannah which
harrison read and there's some suspicion
on both sides as a result the power
dynamics are still way in dexter's
direction as the parent and as hardened
as harrison might be you have to imagine
that there's a part of him that just
wants a dad after growing up without one
this episode thing shifts somewhat where
he's trying to cover up his kill and
that's making it difficult to hide the
weirdness in his relationship with his
son where he should be focusing on
reconnecting and getting to understand
how things got to where they're at at
the moment he's just trying to make sure
that he doesn't go to prison episode 2
in particular had a lot of people
guessing about what harrison's
background would really be maybe he
killed hannah maybe he's a full-blown
serial killer like dexter and for me my
mind didn't really go there i thought
there was a more natural setup in that
dexter is always going to have a problem
making a real relationship with his son
and the fact that he killed matt right
before he brought him in seemed to set
up this kind of situation that we have
in the third episode harrison appears to
be smart based on those tests he has a
sense of justice he befriends ethan and
stands up for him after he sees what
zach and his friends are doing and he
had an in here where he could have came
in and been friends with these guys and
have a much easier time adjusting to
this new place instead he went against
that for what appears to be no other
reason than to stick up for the little
guy although in the process he did come
off a little scary with that choke hold
but there's at least an equal chance
that he picked up those skills in the
foster care system rather than having
some dark passenger and either way
dexter is always going to kind of
suspect that it's interesting how the
interludes with deb are short-lived and
in the few moments where he's not
distracted with harrison or the people
related to the investigation i'm still
enjoying those quite a bit there's a lot
of little side mysteries going on ed
olsen and his story he may be there just
as a red herring as an alternate to kurt
as the main serial killer but hopefully
there's more going on there as well
you've got iris you've got audrey's
parents and her ending up with angela in
the first place and you've got this
podcaster character which has sounded
like an interesting addition since i
first heard about it it's curious that
logan is the one person in town that
seemed to think matt was a good guy and
that might prove interesting as the case
grows cold he seems friendly with dexter
but not in a way that he'd write him off
if clue started the point in his
direction the laser scope killer was
calculated and there's every indication
he's done this exact thing before it
looks like the room she was being held
in was constructed for that exact
purpose in what looks more like a
hunting cabin than someone's home and
he's got everything on hand to do a
professional job of preparing her dead
body i still think it's kirk caldwell
nothing in this episode changed my mind
on that and the idea that he said that
he talked to matt could be related to
him trying to shut down the
investigation as they start searching
different places if he's been killing
people for a long time there's a
definite possibility that there's bodies
out there somewhere and those might turn
up in an extensive search it's still
early we're in an interesting spot and i
think that's a good place to leave
things the whole school shooter angle
kind of feels like it's going to be a
chance for harrison to intervene if
ethan turns out to be troubled in that
way but we'll have to wait and see where
that goes let me know in the comments
what you think about that what you think
about this laser scope killer and what's
going on there and how you think the
season's gonna play out please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon